This is my mom.
I love her.
But during the holiday season, she gets a little chaotic.
Merry Christmas.
Why?
Simple.
She's in charge of getting the presents.
For me, my sister, my brother, my dad, my grandma, grandpa, aunts and my uncles...
...and so on and so on.
She was always leaving herself notes.
On the table, on the refrigerator, in the living room and even on her laptop.
But this year, something is very different.
Now when she sees something for us, she would use her new phone to just select...
...select, select, select and select again.
This way, everything is in one place.
Boom!
Right on her phone.
Cool, right?
She can send it to dad to see what he thinks.
Where's mine?
She can even view her lists on Scrapbook and order her favorites through mobile.
And done.
And that means she can have a peaceful holiday season like the rest of us.
Ready, set, super-duper mom!